how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some very interesting black
panther news now chadwick boseman was
pretty much the perfect black panther
he did an amazing job and he touched the
hearts of a lot of people
and he was an incredibly great role
model but sadly he is no longer with us
and eventually down the road black
panther 2 will happen
and it looks like marvel studios might
already have their plan
on how to move forward something they
were working on prior to chadwick
boseman's passing
they weren't planning to replace black
panther obviously but
perhaps introduce a new one and now
thanks to an
mcu tie-in book the wakanda files we
have discovered that shuri has been up
to
a lot and it looks like she is going to
be our new
black panther so i'll break down
everything the book says and everything
you need to know but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win an
imposter spider-man funko pop so as i
mentioned
there's a tie-in book called the wakanda
files that tells us of some things that
have been happening within the mcu that
you haven't necessarily seen on screen
these things are kind of happening in
the background and as you can guess
based off of the name of the book the
wakanda files it talks about
wakanda and it specifically talks about
what shuri has been up to over the past
couple of years
and the biggest thing that we found out
that shuri has been working on is
creating
a new heart-shaped herb now for those of
you who may not be aware the
heart-shaped herb
is what gives black panther his
abilities and according to the wakanda
files
shuri is not only trying to recreate it
but also trying to make it
stronger according to the book shuri
began looking into a way to
synthesize the heart-shaped herb after
eric killmonger burned the entire supply
in black panther the book says that
shuri even considers stabilizing the
effects of her synthetic herb
by adding some vibranium into the mix
but
she notes that she can't do much until
she has studied a
sample of the original botanical so
shuri is trying to recreate the
heart-shaped herb
but she's also trying to add some
vibranium to it this would mean that
vibranium would be
in the blood of whoever would eat the
heart-shaped herb
now obviously this is experimental but
one can imagine how strong somebody
would be if they actually had vibranium
infused in their blood with the effects
of all the other abilities that the
heart-shaped herb
gives the black panther but the sheer
fact that marvel was already planning on
a way to bring back the heart-shaped
herb
means that at one point in time they
were planning on at least having
somebody
challenge black panther for the throne
now obviously with chadwick passing away
we aren't going to get that
but since shuri is the one that is
creating this new heart-shaped herb and
she is the sister
to t'challa and heir of the throne it
would make perfect sense that she would
be the one to take on the black panther
mantle next
especially if she is in fact the creator
of this new heart-shaped herb because
without that there is no black panther
at least not with all the abilities that
have been passed down from generations
to generations
this also seems the way that marvel
would go because they probably would not
like to replace chadwick boseman
at least at first and marvel studios has
already stated that that is not their
focus right now so in terms of actually
replacing chadwick boseman's black
panther
that probably won't happen for a while
but a new black panther who is his
sister in the movies and really a sister
in real life to him honors his memory
his legacy and fits in the mcu pretty
well especially if you consider the fact
that in the comics she has taken on the
mantle of black panther before
so the story arc in the mcu would work
out the respect to chadwick boseman
would be paid and according to the
wakanda files the story is already set
up in the mcu for sure to create this
new heart-shaped herb and become the
next black panther this doesn't mean
that we won't get another male black
panther down the road but it sure does
look like shuri is going to be
the next one so let me know what you
think about shuri being the one to take
on the black panther mantle
next let me know what you think in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest things
happening in the mcu
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof